what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
as we continue our discussion on Marvel
characters we're going to take a step
away from earthbound and tangible
characters and begin looking more at
intangible characters in this video
we're going to be talking about the
cosmic entities of the Marvel Universe
so before we get too far into this video
there are a couple things that we need
to line out first the first thing is
that we're not going to be talking about
all of the cosmic entities in the Marvel
Universe we're really only going to be
talking about these cosmic entities and
the reason for that will become apparent
in later videos just suffice it to say
that these characters play a very
important role much later on and in our
discussions as this channel progresses
the next thing is that you really need
to free yourself from the notion of
being able to understand the power that
people have and being able to rank
individuals based on the powers that
they have because when it comes to
earthbound characters we can sit down
and we can say well magneto is more
powerful than Polaris and Jean Grey is
more powerful than Charles Xavier
but in this realm of cosmic entities
while there is a hierarchy to power with
among these characters their power is so
extreme that for the most part in their
comparison to earthbound characters
they're all godlike there really is
nothing that earthbound characters can
do for the most part to stop the will of
these particular cosmic entities there
are some characters who have extreme
powers but their powers despite their
extreme nature don't really come close
to challenging the upper echelon of some
of these cosmic entities even the most
the most powerful character in the
Marvel Universe let's say earthbound
character Franklin Richards is on par
with Celestials but Celestials are among
the lowest powered cosmic entities that
exist and we'll talk about that as we
progress through this video so bear in
mind because so little is known about
these cosmic entities there will be some
obscurity in this video and there will
be times where I will simply say that's
the only thing I know how to tell you
because there's nothing else known about
them so when it comes to the the native
the universe that we are native to when
it comes to our universe a lot of these
cosmic entities are confined to it they
don't exist outside of our universe
there are two cosmic entities
that exist in the realm of all of Marvel
that is to say the Marvel multiverse as
a whole there is only one of them and
they appear however they choose to among
every single universe that could
possibly exist or does currently exist
the highest ranking figure I guess so to
speak or the most powerful being in all
of Marvel is the one above all and the
one above all is for all intents and
purposes God now we do not have a
picture of the one above all depicted
here but that's because the one above
all really kind of appears in different
forms based on the circumstances the one
above all is also being known as the
fulcrum or at least is believed to be
that he's a being known as the fulcrum
which is actually a bartender in this
cosmic kind of bar that eternals go to
when they lose their physical form and
is at the bar that they can either
choose to go on to the afterlife or they
can take on a new physical form and
reappear somewhere else the one above
all is is depicted in probably my
favorite way in Fantastic Four and one
of the Fantastic Four comics he's
actually depicted as Jack Kirby the
artist behind pretty much all of the
Marvel characters that we have come to
know and love or at least in the very
early days of their designs there is an
instance where by the Fantastic Four
travelled to a reality far beyond any
known reality that we've ever
encompassed and they actually end up in
the art studio of Jack Kirby and Jack
Kirby's working on a comic and he's
actually having a different character
replaced with the Silver Surfer and he
gets a phone call from his collaborator
and the Fantastic Four kind of like what
in the world is going on you know what
is this this is just kind of weird you
know this is craziness
and at that point Reed Richards face is
disfigured and Jack Kirby erases the
disfigurement with a pencil and redraws
it and the and Reed Richards face is
back to normal and they're just kind of
like in awe like wow this is absolutely
amazing but for us as readers it's
humorous and it's a funny thing to look
at it's kind of a funny panel because
it's it's funny to see you know these
Marvel characters interacting with their
creator both on the pages and in terms
of the Marvel Universe itself and to be
and so and to be in such awe by the
abilities of this creator
and us as readers looking at the acts of
Jack Kirby and seeing it as a mundane
act a guy drawing characters and fixing
some of the the disfigurement so the
characters may have because it's simply
just what he wants to do the next person
down from the one above all is the
Living Tribunal and depicted here The
Living Tribunal is the being all in gold
with a purple cloth over his head now
the reason why is because the Living
Tribunal has three phases I can remember
exactly what each phase stands for I
know one is necessity I think the other
is equity and the third I think is
judgment and and despite the fact that
the Living Tribunal exists as a judge in
and of itself the the face of judgment
is actually a reflection of whoever it
is a living tribunal is talking to in
order to instill the understanding that
people should only judge if they wish to
be judged themselves the Living Tribunal
sits at the judgment of all realities
and he exists to ensure that all the
cosmic laws remain in check they remain
in balance for example during the
Infinity Gauntlet
there is a point whereby a multitude of
cosmic entities come together and ask
the Living Tribunal to look upon
judgment of Thanos and the Living
Tribunal turns down this judgement and
says that there have no cosmic laws have
been broken here because one of the most
base big a basic cosmic laws is that the
the weak are replaced with the strong
and if a person is unable to somehow
maintain their authority or maintain
their control over whether over over
what it is they control whether it be
something as small as an act on the
planet Earth or something as grandiose
as their control over their particular
perception of whatever aspect of the
cosmos they represent then they should
be replaced by someone who can and so
the Living Tribunal looked at Thanos and
said that ohs was simply going to
replace one of the cosmic entities and
there was no cosmic law that was being
broken here because it was the natural
order of things and at that point that
Living Tribunal left and people were
just kind of left to their own devices
to figure out how to defeat Thanos it
was really kind of a shitty circumstance
for a lot of the cosmic entities and
Marvel heroes who were involved in that
particular endeavor
after the Living Tribunal comes a series
of comes pretty much all the other
cosmic entities that are confined to our
universe different variations of them
exist in other universes but the ones
that we see from here on out are based
only in our universe and they cannot
cross over now to that that's the best
of my knowledge I could be wrong here
the highest-ranking person in our
universe is eternity and eternity is the
representation of everything that there
is of time and space life and death
order in chaos he is kind of the
embodiment of all the other eternal or
all the other cosmic entities although
they are still individual beings that
can kind of do their own do their own
thing there really isn't anything that
he can do they cannot do in terms of our
universe he is in effect the one above
all if the one above all were confined
to our particular universe and do not
exist outside of our universe the next
person after that is the watcher and
most notably you ought to the watcher
who watch you the watcher is a member of
a race of beings called the Watchers and
they have incredible power but much
early in the creation of the universe
they took it upon themselves to simply
just observe and record to chronicle the
events of the universe as they unfold
and of course their species will die
when the universe dies and they will be
reborn when the universe is born again
although a pub won't be in the same
fashion that we see them now they may
take on a different form they might be a
different race or they may never become
the Watchers but considering the fact
that they are a cosmic entity they are a
a fabric they are a part of the fabric
of the universe so most likely they will
be reborn in a different form when the
universe dies and is recreated again who
want to The Watcher is really kind of
special here and the reason why I say so
is because we watched The Watcher
periodically we'll take a step away from
the vow of his race and actually
intervene in the actions of a particular
group for example with a planet Earth
before the arrival of the Silver Surfer
watching The Watcher warns the Fantastic
Four of the coming of Galactus and his
Herald and I believe the reason he chose
to do that was because of the potential
for the planet
and the fact that the planet Earth had
the potential to house some of the most
powerful characters in Marvel Universe
that could exist and so we kind of felt
it incumbent on himself to warn the
Fantastic Four of the coming threats so
that a effort could be organized in
order to fight off Silver Surfer and
then eventually fight off Galactus with
the help of Silver Surfer
we watched The Watcher by the way is the
guy who is depicted right behind
eternity he has the blue looking outfit
and he's got the the oversized head the
next two people are kind of two sides of
the same coin and you'll hear me repeat
that maybe one or two times in this
discussion probably one one other time
because a lot of times what you find in
cosmic entities is that they are of one
ideology but they represent that
ideology in two different ways in this
instance it's master order and Lord
chaos and these other characters who
were depicted right behind The Living
Tribunal in the center the guy with the
bald head and the guy with the
weird-looking kind of purple head these
are characters who represent chaos and
order
chaos being the most extreme degree that
is to say no order whatsoever things
just happen there's no reason behind it
it just takes place and there's no way
to really kind of understand it order is
the most strict adherence to order there
is no room for adjustment there's no
room for expansion and growth it's a
very rigid way of organizing things and
of course neither can exist in the
extreme they represent balance if order
were to exist in the extreme then the
universe would eventually just kind of
destroy itself it would it'd be kind of
at a point where it just couldn't exist
because nothing new could come into
fruition it would just be a very
stringent way if chaos existed in the
extreme then the universe would
inevitably destroy itself by the sheer
fact that there would be no order to it
there would be no structure things would
get so out of hand that there would be
no way to confine them and everything
would just kind of come to an end now
because of the fact that those two
cannot exist in extremes there has to be
a balance between the two of them and
they actually came together and formed a
being called the in-betweener
and the in-betweener exists in order to
make sure that balance exists in the
universe
now the next two people are again two
sides of the same coin and this is the I
guess I believe the the being mistress
love and sire hate now these are the
characters next to Galactus the woman
who looks like or who has blonde hair
and a pink outfit and then the woman who
is all in blue and looks like a female
apocalypse they are kind of the
emotional embodiment of love and hate
and they represent those exact two
things all the love and hate that exists
throughout the cosmos are embodied by
these two characters and because of that
of course they can manipulate all facets
of love and hate they can inspire love
and hate and any particular being so
long is that being doesn't supersede
their particular powers now of course we
see Galactus and the reason why Galactus
is considered to be a cosmic entity is
for a couple reasons one he again is
kind of a reflection of balance but
balance in terms of the or of the
universe that's spiraling out of control
and kind of spiraling out into
overpopulation so to speak Galactus due
to the fact that he is a being composed
of pure energy travels from one planet
to the other and feeds on the energy of
those planets in order to to feed
himself in order to ensure that he
survives and it is in this form that he
differentiates from cosmic entities in a
few different ways when it comes to the
cosmic entities they are amoral they
have no care about what goes on in the
realm of the Marvel Universe all they do
is exist to ensure that their roles are
played out Galactus displays
periodically a guilt over consuming the
life of countless civilizations and
bringing them to add to a total entity
really kind of detests his existence in
the way that it is but understands that
his role is a necessity in the universe
at the same time he actually has a
physical form when it comes to the
cosmic entities they have no real
physical form with the exception of
maybe the Celestials but that's kind of
up for debate Galactus is tangible he
could be touched he can be punched he
can be destroyed or in the instance of
Marvel Zombies he can be consumed the
form that he takes on here is really a
form that is most suitable to him
and most I guess conservative for the
amount of energy that he needs in order
to maintain himself this is really a way
for him to channel his energies in a way
that regulate his body but keep him from
consuming energy unnecessarily
now below Galactus we see two beings
that are kind of shrouded in shadow and
they look kind of weird maybe like
transformers or something
these are Celestials and Celestials
again or at the bottom tier of cosmic
entities they are extremely weak
compared to virtually all the other
cosmic entities that we see aside from
maybe Galactus these Celestials are
really kind of responsible or at least
it's believed they're responsible for
the creation of mutant kind and of
course as we discussed in our video with
apocalypse they had granted apocalypse
their power and apocalypse had used this
power under the agreement that in the
future prices a price would have to be
fade paid future payments I think is how
they refer to it and of course they took
apocalypse away in Apocalypse you know
of course came back but they are going
to extremely advanced kind of alien so
to speak and they kind of exist as a
hybrid they kind of exist in between you
could consider them to be an extremely
advanced alien race or you can consider
them to be a construct of the universe
itself any and a necessity I do not know
that much about Celestials in terms of
their existence in the Marvel Comics so
I can't really give you much more
information than that I'm sure
information is out there to be read I
simply just don't know that off the top
of my head the next person that we see
is the guy who kind of looks like Silver
Surfer but it's composed of clouds and
and I guess stars and different things
like that in planets this of course is
Chronos and he is the master of time he
can manipulate all facets of time he can
stop time he can slow time I imagine he
can probably even bring time to an end
if he chose to and this is where things
get kind of hairy because time and space
of course kind of coexist and so to
bring an end to time would be to bring
it into the universe itself and I doubt
he could do that since he can't simply
control the universe in and of itself
with regards to these cosmic entities
these are pretty much the limit to the
discussion that we're going to have
and again it's important that you take a
step away from the idea of relating to
these beings based on the abilities of
what they can do based on their power on
who they can manipulate what they can do
and how they can manipulate those powers
because when it comes to the power of
these characters it gets very very
muddled and it gets very very cloudy and
aside from maybe eternity the one above
all or the Living Tribunal there really
isn't a hierarchy in terms of who is
stronger than Who there really isn't a a
comparison here each of them has a power
within their own right although it's
possible that they can destroy another
being now when I say that we're kind of
ending the discussion on the the cosmic
entities here you may have noticed that
I left out one character and the
character that I left out here is the
stranger and he's the the older guy with
the the green cloak and the red outfit
in the white hair
the stranger is something that I know
nothing about and no one does the
stranger is an enigma to everyone no one
knows how he got here no one knows where
he's from no one knows what his purpose
is he's just here and he's just this
incredibly astronomically powerful
character and he really seems like one
of these guys that was just classified
as a cosmic entity due to the amount of
power that he has and the fact that no
one knows anything about him and so
that's it that's pretty much it I don't
know what to tell you about the stranger
I don't I don't I don't know enough
about him if there is information out
there I don't know enough about him to
be able to tell you what it is I just
know that periodically he shows up he
shows up in the in the comics when
Thanos captures or I guess when he
combines with the heart of the universe
he shows up during the Infinity Gauntlet
he may even show up a few of the times
but for the most part I don't really
know that much about him so again keep
this conversation in the back of your
head keep these characters in the back
of your head because they are going to
become very very important much later on
as we progress the future discussions in
this in this channel and I will say
although you probably figured it out
already I will say that these characters
are all involved in the Infinity
Gauntlet so with that being said I'm
going to go ahead and bring this video
to and I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and
we'll catch you guys later peace